[Applaudissements]
alors on a tous une activité à auby
peut-être un sport qui vous prend et en
vendant ou réalisé avec passion oui part
ça pendant des heures et des heures
et moi ma passion c'est bien lui
ça sent plutôt qu'à 15 ans il ya 15 ans
finalement vous avez une passion c'est
et bmx et je les deux fois et en fait
quand j'ai commencé le bmx tous les tops
riders les professionnels avec 12 plus
de 20 ans 25 23 24 ans et c'était
impossible de croire vous pouvez être
fort avant et voilà que potes on pouvait
passer énormément de temps
comprendre la théorie de figure comment
tu fais un 3/6 commencé ma clique
superman et settat et finalement un
autre petite ville on avait très peu
d'accès à la théorie c'est peu de
magazines sa dette ou des états unis
les cassettes vidéo au possible ceux qui
ont connu on avait des 17 2 3 par an
s'est passé
sa calandre entre potes et on les use et
jusqu'à de pouvoir rend fou
et puis finalement aujourd'hui quand je
regarde l'évolution du sport de bmx
d'autres énormément de jeunes sont de
plus en plus forts de plus en plus tôt
et dans le bmx tous les tops riders pour
moi de 18 ans et c'est une évolution un
petit peu globale dans tous les sports
plus comment quand on regarde à l'image
des derniers jo d'hiver ou énormément de
jeunes ont gagné beaucoup de médailles
très jeune avec -18 ans de rock alors je
me suis posé un peu la question qu'est
ce que ces personnes ont aujourd'hui
pour n'avait pas à l'époque
donc effectivement le matériel l'accès
au matériel de qualité
j'ai un petit chou accès aux soins ou si
c'est facile ou pc
vous avez accès aux soins c'est beaucoup
plus simple et puis surtout il ya une
évolution qui arrivait sur internet
et moi j'ai vu à l'arrivée d'internet
fait partie de cette génération qui a vu
arriver à atteindre
je vais arriver les premiers modems qui
faisait un bruit bizarre quand il se
connecte et qui veut arriver
msn messenger est aussi netscape le
premier navigateur web vous équipe a
pour téléchargements niveau d'eau à la
tante 15 20 minutes dans cette très
mauvaise qualité est très souvent
finalement on regarde même pas et vos
vidéos vous en comprennent pas ça fait
plutôt deux ou trois fois à leurs hommes
du coup ce qui libère intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec l'internet
on peut avoir accès à des vidéos à des
photos à des tutos même pour apprendre
cette théorie très très vite et passe
effectivement beaucoup plus de temps à
jouer voire expérimentés alors vous pas
avant de vous parler d'apprentissage du
futur parlons de l'apprentissage des
bases de l'apprentissage et parlant de
l'apprentissage animal chez les animaux
sauvages le monde d'hier tout
l'apprentissage se fait par
l'observation par expérimentation par
des mimiques copié sur ses parents et
quand vous vous étiez bébé vous avez
effectivement fonctionné comme ça
également et c'est les études d'un
psychologue et biologistes de suisse
jean piaget qui a effectivement mis en
valeur que génétiquement les décoder
comme ça on est codé pour apprendre par
l'expérience par le faire alors je vous
parlais d'une deuxième expérience une
deuxième vingt deuxième parallèle qu'ils
devaient tous connaître l'éducation en
france aujourd'hui nos étudiants
collégiens lycéens passent plus de six
heures par jour assis et finalement par
rapport à toute la théorie conte à
prendre puisque on ingurgite on
expérimente que très peu tout ce qu'on
apprend
et je suis sûr que vous aussi vous êtes
endormi pendant un cours de math
soporifique de 15 minutes après la pause
on s'est bien entendu moi c'était
l'anglais ont visité tester l'engin et
l'anglais finalement je les appelle 25
ans plus tard je suis arrivé dans un
pays
presque bloquée a pas savoir parler
anglais est la seule langue c'est des
anglais est forcément et j'ai
expérimenté cette langue est en fait en
quelques mois j'ai appris qu'il faut
capillaire j'aurais dû apprendre dans 15
ans et donc finalement j'ai énormément
appris deux choses comme ça en
expérimentant en apprenant la théorie
par la suite l'un des premiers principes
d'apprentissage qu'on appelle le
testament en anglais j'apprends
j'apprends par l'oncle petits
professionnels la formation toulonnaise
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous formez
votre pc votre smartphone de votre
tablette en accès internet de l'accès à
des formations de qualité souvent vous
mettre en place du vally dès que ça
fonctionne donc ça fonctionne pas et
donc vous pouvez apprendre grâce à
internet de l'intelligence d'énormément
de personnes des milliards de personnes
et moi même j'ai appris énormément de
choses en ligne qui m'aurait demandé des
heures et des heures de présence y est
et finalement les dago j pour l'apel
également la pédagogie inverser la
prendre la théorie sans contrainte
ensuite je mets en place alors
qu'aujourd'hui pour l'apprentissage du
futur on parle de deux grands mouvements
il y en a un qui l'a pas trouvée par les
mélodies la mi octobre
le premier c'est l'apprentissage par les
méthodes freiner nous empêche de méthode
freinet c'est j'apprends par
l'expérience des autres c'est
l'expérience des autres qui m'aide à
prendre partagent avec moi et j'en ai la
deuxième forme de pédagogie c'est la
pédagogie montessori
j'apprends par l'expérimentation et par
le jeu et cette pédagogie date de plus
de 110 ans la première école a vu le
jour à rome en 1907 il ya plus de 20000
épaules aujourd'hui dans le monde à
pédagogie montessori et finalement c'est
pédagogique et très accessible puisque
c'est souvent des écoles qui sont privés
donc vous êtes acceptons de ne pas avoir
accès à cette pédagogie
mais aujourd'hui il ya un moyen de
hacker cette pédagogie c'est internet
internet ça me permet d'expérimenter
d'apprendre de l'expérience d'un
milliard de personnes
mais internet c'est aussi
des débats on dit souvent qu'on ne
mérite ni sol isole les gens n'y a
jamais eu autant de personnes qui sont
mis en réseau qui entreprennent qui
essayent de résoudre des sujets parfois
complexes aux quatre coins du monde et
ces entrepreneurs là j'en suis l'un
d'eux effectivement depuis plus de dix
ans j'accompagne des chefs d'entreprise
leur équipe à être améliorer leur
bien-être dans une entreprise améliorer
leurs processus et puis on travaille
souvent en équipe est la pire des choses
qui peut arriver c'est pour reste figé
dans une salle à essayer de brainstorm
et enfin du remue méninges à essayer de
réfléchir à une solution idéale qui
n'arrivera jamais dans la salle et
finalement mon expérience la meilleure
chose à faire c'est de mettre en place
cette petite solution ce petit bout de
solutions de l'ajuster de l'améliorer et
ensuite d'entreprendre tout son
cheminement et finalement chose la plus
intéressante la plus importante c'est
pour prendre tout ce processus
d'apprentissage et finalement le
résultat en est que secondaire alors ce
qui est super marrant également avec le
numérique c'est qu'on peut rendre sexy
et cool activités qui ne sont pas de
prime abord
prenons un exemple des banques des
assurances choisir votre banque ou votre
assurance c'était compliqué pendant un
moment mais aujourd'hui c'est hyper fun
père lui dit vous pouvez changer
rapidement et des comparateurs voulait
par exemple ou si également se faire des
cadeaux pour noël et des applications
qui disent pour ça ça c'est un peu la
galère pour vous pouvez choisir
l'algorithme faisable pour vous et qui
vous et 17e rangs de s'assurer et donc
moyen d'un thème qui n'est pas très fier
de cette base dans l'est ou pas c'est
l'activité par games travaille depuis
des années c'est l'industrie et l'un
d'eux ce qui sépare le drc site beaucoup
de monde est à mon avis si je vous dis
mon industrie ou match qui va vous
arriver en tête c'est plutôt celle là
l'industrie des années 60 a convié hier
que nous et pas très fun alors que moins
à l'industrie c'est plutôt ça ans du
sweat future industrie demain et donc
quand j'ai créé mon entreprise et la
start up j'ai voulu aller un peu plus
loin que proposait des autres conseils
et des formations
je voulais également proposé un jeu ce
jeu je vais vous
pas physique et voulu digitalisées alors
je souhaite aussi avec des personnes du
numérique et on a associé l'industrie le
conseil est lui même et on a utilisé
pour ce jeu des mécaniques jeu vidéo et
puis on avancer dans la création de ce
jeu plus on s'est dit que finalement nos
méthodes de pédagogie qui existait un
peu avant et des a ses limites en termes
de collaboration
c'était très compliqué pour moi de
former en vigueur dans ces heurts les
personnes qui avaient des profils très
hétérogène en peter il fallait
absolument pas la fin toutes ces
personnes elles mêmes xoom du coup on a
un peu plus loin on est allé un peu plus
loin et on a créé l'école lucie l'école
de l'industrie du futur et dans laquelle
vous allez apprendre des notions des
bases des mini compétences par des mini
jeux comme des jeux quand ils crachent
sur votre sur votre ce vote soit sur
votre smartphone et puis vous allez
mettre ça en place dans des défis
beaucoup plus contraint avec des temps
avec des objectifs à atteindre avec de
l'argent à respecter et puis vous allez
même pouvoir certifier votre pitance en
ligne en passant des qcm et en
échangeant avec une communauté et donc
quand on mixe un sujet qui n'est pas
très sexy comme l'industrie avec le jeu
vidéo qui est beaucoup plus sexy et
beaucoup plus dans l'air du temps
voilà ce que l'on obtient une interface
de jeu vidéo dans lequel vous allez
devoir apprendre différentes motions là
vous voyez fanel différentes missions
des différents défis un défi dans lequel
vous allez avoir des contraintes de
temps objectif d'argent et puis une
simulation d'entreprise virtuelle
un peu comme un sioux city dans lequel
vous allez utiliser les outils à droite
de l'écran que vous aurez appris dans
les différentes notions et vous allez
les mettre en place pour voir si ça
fonctionne bien si vous arrivez à gérer
votre
et puis on imagine comme ça déployer de
la production à la logistique au service
qualité pour voir apprendre différentes
choses et donc tout l'intérêt ce jeu
c'est de pouvoir échouent et sans risque
et derrière en apprendre apprendre des
choses qu'on a besoin d'apprendre et
dupont peut même qu'il était directement
sa performance en ligne
on peut gagner des étoiles dennis brown
et même des frais certification dans la
dans l'avenir alors du coup imaginé cet
outil dans les mains des nouvelles
générations
imaginez le nombre d'autres termes vous
pourrez aborder l'écologie futur
l'hôpital le futur la ville du futur par
exemple imaginer ces écoles qui pourrait
être digital et l'irréel
du coup on oblige succès pas de
supprimer les écoles telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui on ne sait plus de
des contraintes la formation de faire en
sorte qu'on peut apprendre différentes
théories facilement nous on veut quand
on veut
et puis prendre plus de temps pour
expérimenter pour jouer un peu comme
quand j'étais sur mon gars mix et puis
quoi le solde de type c'était de
m'amuser de jouer d'apprendre de
nouvelles figures et passer du temps à
apprendre la théorie est donc finalement
ajouté on sait que génétiquement
fonctionne beaucoup mieux en temps
d'apprentissage en faisant en
expérimentant alors du goût des écoles
surtout les professeurs les consultants
intervenant pfizer ses épaules redevenir
des coaches les experts pour accompagner
et différents apprenant en ligne morning
d'ailleurs et puis du coup ces écoles
adviendrait des lieux d'expérimentation
et lieu ouvert à tout le monde avec un
seul objectif c'est de donner accès à
l'action à tout le monde et vous qu en
pensez vous
[Applaudissements]